all right it shows that it shows that we
are live Michael Collins of the
wandering wolf Channel it is a pleasure
to connect with you uh thank you for
coming on today we've already met a few
times uh in person and we've really hit
it off on the same wavelength about a
lot of things and brother you are you
are traveling the world you've been
to hold on one second I got my volume on
my Rumble thing going here forgive me
now we're good uh so you've traveled the
world you've been all over the place you
just got back from Easter Island you've
been to balbec you've been to Egypt
you've been to Peru uh what other places
have you
been uh angor
wat
uh golly obviously it's stonehinge
places like that right in Europe uh all
over
Bolivia um tiwanaku Puma
punu um man a lot a lot of different
places all over the world yeah it's been
uh Japan
Korea wow yeah a little about you so
your prior military you had served
overseas um before getting into
youtubing you were in a sales position
and one of the things that we have in
common as we both basically pulled the
rip cord stopped doing the corporate
world and then decided to pursue a
passion of you know traveling the world
and seeing ancient civilizations and
exploring the Mysteries and how I came
across you is that you went to this
spectacular place in Montana called The
Sage wall that nobody's heard of uh for
example my girlfriend's family lives in
Montana uh about two hours away and
they've never even heard of this place
and so I come across your video and I'm
like this looks like a a ancient
megalithic wall I'm like could it be uh
mostly natural could it be man-made
could it be a combination of the two and
then I started seeing you know going
down the rabbit hole of your channel and
seeing that like you had traveled to so
many different places so um tell me just
where do you want to start off with this
like to everyone listening let me just
say we are streaming live on Rumble and
YouTube right now and you have some new
data that has just come out at the sage
wall involving ground radar and we're
going to get into that a little bit
later uh after we talk for a little bit
we'll move this over exclusively on to
rumble so let's like save that for a
second and and let me just like straight
up ask
you well what is the sage wall
we're trying to figure that out I I'll
tell you right now you know it is it's
interesting that you said that uh about
Montana and people not knowing about
Montana because there it it really has
been going under the radar for quite a
while and um you know this when I walked
up on the site when I saw it online I
knew it was a place that I had I I I
felt that I could contribute something
there in terms of like getting the Drone
footage would be a perspective that
would really highlight the site and um I
I really feel like that's what's kind of
brought it to the for front it's just
seeing how straight this place is but
walking up on it was very similar to um
visiting sites like saak wuman and
places like that that just were kind of
like are you kidding me when when you
walk up on it in person and um you know
it's it's explained away as a dyke or a
geological formation most of the time
but it has a lot of different features
to it that are not typical of dkes um
you know that I spent some time looking
at it is not similar in those regards
and the way in the level of its
straightness and the horizontal pattern
and and a bunch of other stuff that we
will get into um but it
um I think the the fun thing about Sage
Wallace the way it posed that that
question what is going on here and I
love a good mystery and a good adventure
and so this was right up my alley um
I've been out going out there now for
two years and working with the property
owners Chris and Linda and uh they have
been amazing at uh allowing me um access
to the site and getting all this
information and being part of a process
and so I I think sharing all of this
with everybody um has been a lot of fun
it's been a lot of fun filming it and
it's really exciting chasing down these
answers and finding a bunch of
information um uh that's that's exciting
um to to kind of um to learn about the
site that's ongoing and real quick like
to touch on what you just said is that
one of the coolest things about this
place is that it's so accessible
especially for people here in the United
States because in the US if you want to
go see some ancient stuff you're flying
to Peru you're flying to Egypt you're
you know international travel but like
so I'm in Phoenix um or at least the
Phoenix Metro area and I could jump on a
plane fly into Boseman in about two
hours and then less than an hour from
there I'm at the sage wall so like
what's so fun about this is besides the
fact that it's mystery where it's like
what exactly is this place but it's a
site that everyone could easily access
and for not that much money you could
get you know a $200 plane ticket and and
rent a car and be out there you know
later in the afternoon and you know you
and I were talking about this like
debating like you know or or discussing
the debate rather on whether this place
is natural manmade or combination of the
two and the fact that if nothing else
this is a place that finally like you
can have you know geology students
history students a place that people can
go out to and and get off their butts
and go get some some fresh air and go
Breathe In the Pines get some sun and
and go see this for themselves 100%
agree there's this is a no lose
situation so there you know a lot of
people want to come down on one side of
the fence or the other whether it's a
geological formation or whether it's
potentially man-made or has man-made
influence um ultimately by doing the
research we're contributing to either
side at the end of the day so we're
gathering information in a way that's
going to be um I think beneficial
whichever way it ends up going obviously
I would love to discover a new ancient
man-made site um but like I said either
way we're we're working towards
something that's going to contribute uh
one way or the other and the the process
is fun and like you said this is
something that North America is uh
notoriously devoid of megalithic sites
you know it just ends in Mexico why is
that and this is a place that you can go
and experience and you're going to H I
mean walking up on this wall is is it's
just incredible so even if you're a
traveler like I am I go to a lot of
different natural places as well um I've
been all over Iceland and different
places that are just full of natural
features that are just breathtaking this
is up there so you know you don't really
need an answer to the question to go
enjoy the site and it is open to the
public right and I should point out to
people and by the way we're going to be
showing you guys a bunch of photos today
we got the folders up and I should
mention and and I I you know I'm going
to do the name drop for you but like
your video so about you've been sharing
the content of your own travels to the
the sage wall Montana for two years now
and one of your videos particularly got
a few hundred thousand views and you
brought it on the map I came across I'm
like what the heck well come to find out
you had gotten the attention of Graham
Hancock and then I made a share on this
on Instagram and Joe Rogan saw it and so
now they're both following you and
you've done something which is so rare
in this realm where a lot of people are
talking about the same topics and it's
rare to come across something new and
with you putting this out there like
you're the guy now um there's a lovely
woman named uh is it Judy
or Julie Miss Ryder uh she has been out
there for years we should give her some
love um it was kind of her spot but like
unfortunately her videos on it got and I
say this with love but so few views that
nobody had heard of it then you make a
video it gets hundreds of thousands of
views and all of a sudden everybody has
heard about it and like I said you got
the the attention of people such as
Graham Hancock and Joe Rogan speaking of
which you just had dinner with them with
uh Graham hanock and his wife and then
had drinks with Joe Rogan just a few
weeks ago in Austin I shouldn't name
drop but I'm gonna plug you to make you
look cool because you are and now all of
a sudden you're mingling in these cool
circles where it's like you know you've
just contributed something so great
because this be real dude to anyone
listening and and maybe if you could
prepare some some pictures real quick of
Sall so people can get an idea but um if
this site is in any way a remnant of a
lost ancient civilization of North
America this is going to rewrite the
textbooks this is an unbelievably big
deal like this this just be clear the
there are natural Boulders out there and
the question that we're at now is did a
lost ancient civilization potentially
tens of thousands of years ago construct
this wall into the flush nature that as
we see it today hundreds 300 plus feet
long is it um and and so if this turns
out to be like an actual remnant of an
ancient civilization it's a GameChanger
like right now we were talking about
this earlier it's like so many people
are looking at these Footprints in North
America that are like 20,000 years old
23,000 years old and it's like rewriting
the textbooks in itself I'm like well if
this is a a long lost megalithic wall
that is next level yeah uh completely
rewrites history it it specifically for
North America but the implications there
are worldwide 100% And um you know it's
always been a question of mine as I've
been traveling is why are there no
megalithic structures that we found in
North America every other continent on
the planet you know we have these
structures everywhere that just blow our
mind and can't be explain and it just
not in North America right and we've got
you know we dat people being here
back you know thou long enough to have
to have done it so um yeah it it's an
interesting question and definitely a a
mystery worth unraveling if we can and
Sage wall is uh definitely the whole
Montana area is full of a lot of very
interesting features and stuff but Sage
wall stands alone in its uniqueness in
terms of being so similar to some of
these other sites around the world and
its and its construction its
straightness the the the the blocking of
uh the wall and and different stuff and
I think you made an excellent point
there uh a minute I believe about the um
the the influences of of possibly being
man-made but also being old enough to
show weathering and erosion as well on
the site so you have to kind of take
that into consideration there are things
you you're looking at things that can
negate each other if you just firmly put
your feet in one camp or the other
totally I think you need to look at the
possibilities and really remain
open-minded to the fact that you could
have both levels of influences going on
here at the site right on do you can you
bring up some this's this's show some
slides um and show people the wall that
we're dealing with and that it looks
like Pinal or polygonal stones that have
been pieced together and that's what
we're talking about is that did people
come on to these natural features and
piece it together because once you see
it the first thought that goes through
your head it's like there's no way
that's natural there just is no way and
and let's just share while you're
bringing up these slides I'll share with
people that the scientific explanation
is that this is a volcanic Dyke and a
you could look at pictures from around
the world of examples of volcanic dkes
and this looks nothing like it it is not
it it is different um all right so hold
on I'm going to add you to the stage
here so just real quick fire just okay
so wow what an epic photo of how
straight that is let me see if I can
just isn't that amazing will you uh take
it just do a little uh a showand tell
dump just keep showing photos so people
watching look and think for themselves
yeah and so let me just um use this
right here this picture as an
opportunity to go over just a few of the
things that we've been doing as far as
studying for the site we 3D imaged the
site I you know uh part of a an awesome
group of guys that are doing independent
um stuff out there um some in Montana
some other places um and my buddy Sean
is uh um been contributing some 3D uh
Imaging and stuff that we've been able
to plug in so we've done a 3D imaging of
this site where he's been able to look
at just the exact straightness of this
wall and it is just mindboggling just
how perfectly straight the wall is now
sometimes you can see there looks like
little curbage in here but if you look
at the bottom line right there just how
straight that is you'll get an idea
photography can come sometimes throw
things off a little bit we put this in
programming in that 3D imaging program
and it's just showing just an incredible
level of straightness this this shot
right here really showcases that it
really does and then right there you can
see that that happy face with the arrow
that's a person down there oh wow that's
a six foot tall person down there as the
wall is just massive so you know
hopefully that can give you a sense of
scale here but um you know actually how
tall it is is it excuse
me looks that that is definitely uh
something I should know off hand but I'm
gonna um show us some more photos and
we'll let we'll let we all we'll figure
it out together we people leave a chat
like oh that's easy 25 feet look at it I
could tell because we have measurements
of all of this uh but there's a good
other top down pitcher
um and they're from Drone footage that I
took keep going I want to see from like
if you could show us one of the ones
from ground level when you see it face
on because that's one of the ones that
really
just so here's a good I should also let
me give you a quick shout out that in
your travels around the world and
documenting various different sites
you've had multiple network television
uh companies purchase your footage and
use it in shows that are on mainstream
television now
yeah um yeah I've had uh content
featured uh the Drone footage is really
popular and that's been just hugely
instrumental in my travels I make sure
to take a drone with me everywhere I
go and um um because it just as you can
tell it it adds an entire other label
perspective to to any site um but when
you're watching it on YouTube or
anywhere else um uh it just enhances the
you know it helps you get a
scale in terms of perspective instead of
being on on the ground the whole time
right but yes yeah thank you that's been
um it's been a lot of fun being able to
to to kind of collaborate with um
different network programs and stuff
like that um and using the footage uhh
for those things um the
uh yeah okay Nubs see this is this is
evidence that humans have at least if
nothing else did things to these stones
in Asian times go back uh well here I'll
let you present go ahead I'm sorry okay
so I have um and I think I had it here
so the photo on the left is from the
sage
wall and the photo on the right I was in
Egypt about six months before these are
side by side comparisons you have a
square cutout there is a channel right
some of this is hard to see um it is
because of the color of the stone I know
I've seen I've tried to take these are
this is the hardest Stone to take photos
of based on its complexion its color
because it doesn't the
same with your eye but there is a
channel going from that stone Square
cutout just like on the right that goes
down into a circular Basin type
depression and then the rock is broken
there at the bottom so you have the half
of the circle before the break but you
can see the the the um similarities
between the two you also have um some
other features and and and the
surrounding features at the site is
something that I've tried
to you know really Hammer home with
people to to make them aware of that
they've been less obviously everybody
focuses on the main feature which is the
wall but there's lots of surrounding
evidence we have these cup holes um in a
stone that's right next to the wall and
these can be found all over the site
there's a couple other ones that are
just perfect holes and Stones right next
to the wall that I found on this most
recent trip up there um and you can find
these types of uh depress
these couoles in all over the world I've
seen them on every continent um you have
areas like this that look carved
out could be for Tool Sharpening or what
have you but evidence that at least
people have been there Native Americans
whoever but have been there and been to
this site if nothing else and I will say
um Chris uh the property owner is when
we've talked you know they've that whole
area has um been used used by Native
Americans for quite a long extensive
period of time and in fact this entire
area this part of Montana used to be
used as a Gathering Place for different
tribes so there's there's been
arrowheads and all sorts of artifacts
and stuff found all throughout the area
um you have areas like like this that
are very similar to Nubs found all over
the world that are sticking out of parts
of the rock the nub phenomena let me
give a quick shout out because I want to
give these guys some love there's a g a
bunch a group of gentlemen on Twitter
that you know they're kind of like this
nub group where they share these these
this phenomena uh there's Andrew from
ancient history criticisms there's Phil
from ancient alternative view there's
the stone nub language there's a few
other gentlemen and I'm I'm on the spot
here but these things are found like
five continents around the world um
sorry to cut you off but I want to give
them some love because a lot of people
AR sharing their work yeah good friends
of mine they're all doing amazing work
um you know Andrew Phil crisen Ziggy all
these guys are that stuff and keeping up
with it and dropping information from
places all over the world and collecting
that data right which is great because
that a few more photos of this so people
can see that like how unlikely it is to
be a natural thing that people have out
here and screwed around so you know the
the the Nubs is
um I'm not you know I take pictures of
the Nubs everywhere I go when I'm
traveling so you'll see them featured in
my videos and stuff if you pay attention
um I'm not quite as indepth into it as
the gentleman that we just mentioned who
are doing amazing work um on on on the
Nubs um a lot of times people try to uh
describe these as um inclusions so
something that if you had a Dy or a
volcanic formulation from a geological
perspective it might have been some kind
of abnormality that was then I
guess in the stone and then weathered
away somehow creating these Nubs and so
if I guess if you broke that off there'd
be something different in there but you
know it is very similar and being that
it you know this right here collectively
with all the surrounding evidence and
then the straightness of the wall and
all the other features of the site I
feel like it's just it should be
included in terms of more sub U uh you
know surrounding evidence corroborating
evidence for the and then we can work
towards you know getting into these more
in depth but as far as collecting data
right now visually and through footage
definitely something that I would want
to include is these nums and different
Stu keep show keep going down lot you
have because I already know what photos
you have so I'm like bro keep going like
you got some killer shots um that is
undoubtedly marks of of human
intervention but like let's see some of
the the poly the polygonal stuff because
this what the most amazing stuff I want
to get people's attent yeah see look at
this so I love this spot right here it's
just up a little bit further back from
the wall um but you have this this
blocking type of uh stuff going on all
over the place and you know I had an
interesting conversation with um uh
Chris the property owner actually
today um pointing out and I'm gonna say
it wrong now that I brought it up but um
you know a lot of the arguments
sometimes are about these vertical lines
going all the way down and that nobody
builds that which is untrue he was
telling me about in construction um you
know the
um using vertical stuff stuff sometimes
uh for uh Expansion Joints I believe is
that what he said but the um you know
for it to breathe so if you if you're
building something on ground or
something sometimes you don't want
things to you ever seen that wall at
Machu Picchu it's been on Twitter lately
where it's kind of collapsed on the
sides but the the middle has maintained
its shape sometimes you want a little
bit of movement right you would like you
want the wall to shift if especially if
you're in a seismic area um but we'll
you know we get into all that as we
continue to
gather data but here's the main thing
and ugly enough someone pointed it out
on social media the other day there's
another wall like type thing up and over
the hill back at least a half a mile
from this that was and they pointed it
out they pulled my footage showed that
picture and pointed it out to me as if
well this is just another formation
right there isn't this pretty well no
the other one is uneven and it's
vertical nothing but vertical brakes all
line what we don't see in a lot of or
any that I've really seen is the the
horizontal stacking like this in dikes
right so if you go and you start looking
up diyes um and examples of dyes all
over there most of the time they look
very shattered and broken off in pieces
as if they're been forced and cracked
and up and stuff like that but anywhere
where you have solid pieces together
that are fitted
together they're not usually
horizontally straight like this Sage
wall is unique in its appearance and its
formation so right if this is an you
know um if this is a natural formation
it is a very unique natural
formation right but these the horizontal
blocking and stacking here I think um is
is something that definitely makes the
site and you'll notice there's similar
is my mouse showing up here yeah okay
yeah you notice a similar type of rocks
structure when you get to the top of the
Rocks they become smaller they're all
similar for the entire length of the
wall so you know and we know that this
goes down much further and some of that
I know we're g to save for for for here
in a little bit from the results from
the
ground penetrating radar but I can tell
you right now that this goes down much
further and we know that for a fact
right now so this this this area goes
down approximately 15 feet down the
length of the wall to to a lower level
and I'll tell you what we found down
there yeah hold on that thought yeah
because we're gonna I want to we're
gonna bring that exclusively to rumble
in a few um do you have some other
photos you could share of people
standing next to this in front of it so
they can understand how big this thing
is I know you have a whole number of
photos um let me see anything before I
because this thing's a behemoth yeah oh
there just and I'll show you that that's
the other one that is right there yeah
at the wall that
circular whatever you want to call it uh
is
not that's that's human intervention
right there no doubt isn't that amazing
right now to people listening it doesn't
mean the whole wall is is an ancient
historic you know Monument but like
we're just we're setting up the stage
here which is like people have been
there that's a fact which I don't think
anyone would disagree with that'd be
silly but um that is undoubtedly you
know evidence that ancient Americans
have done some sort of tooling out there
um and and let me know if you're if
you're looking for photos I could always
bring up some of mine from the Montana
Mega list I had uh which are pretty much
all your photos too
I've got the I'm bringing up the ones
with the um the geophysicist that was
out there working doing the uh work my
my problem is I keep doing what we were
having the issue with before we hopped
on okay I got you open up Photoshop so
I've got it
now and let me share it with you here
while you're while you're getting that
together let me just mention something
we were talking about earlier
uh so since you have brought attention
to this this site is now being monitored
far more uh closely by various
government agencies that study geology
uh as well as companies that do
um uh what do they do just exploration
of ancient sites what was it um no like
so basically this it's a company based
out of England I'm gonna be releasing a
lot of this kind of um at some point in
regards to um what is going on
there but
they they were contracted through the
government for doing surveys out there
all around that land so you know it was
protected land um it's and it's so this
is from private property that backs up
against government land okay that's a
huge you gotta all right so real quick
people need to understand this because
this an unbelievably important point
this is on private property and it's one
of the reasons why this has been unknown
for so many years this is in somebody's
backyard that owns tons of acreage and
they didn't even know about this site
until what year was it that they had to
dig out because this whole site when
they came across it was covered in
foliage right and half buried will you
explain that to everybody so they
understand that it's private property
and it was consumed by the Earth in up
until how many years ago yeah it's been
well over 20 years so I think it was
back in the 90s uh when Chris and Linda
discovered it on their property they
moved out there to Montana to you know
they had this dream of building this
Retreat and um you know uh
um a uh you know kind of an eco-friendly
type um thing going on there and uh by
the way you can go to the website and
they they have such a great story listed
out there plug it right now what's their
website and because it's sag mountain
center.com people can Google it and then
you could set up a tour you can call now
just to clarify it's call it's
appointment only you call it email do
not show up show up right yeah do not
just show up yeah yeah that way on cool
um because this is somebody's this is
somebody's property people their private
home and Business right and now it's all
snowed in but once the snow melts you
know later in the spring you're free to
go there I was supposed to go out there
this summer with you and I couldn't
swing it um but this with this snow
thaws coming up this next spring and
fall uh summer 100% got to go there yeah
that'd be a great trip man and it it
yeah they they they typically will let
you come up and tour the site for um
between May depending on the weather um
and the snow melt into I think they shut
down in maybe around August July August
sometime in there um and and so because
they do have to leave themselves enough
time to do prep work for winter that
whole area gets snowed in immensely
sometimes but you have to go to go to
the website SES mountain
center.com and you'll want to um
schedule and book a time there and you
need to sign some release stuff and and
and make sure to agree if you're filming
or doing Dr own work or anything like
that or if you're doing anything like
that to to to get all that okay with
them um but you can go visit it and like
you said earlier um uh this is a place
in the states that you can go see you
can you could drive here if you're close
enough it's a simple flight and there's
lots of other stuff and amazing things
to do around the surrounding area so you
know there's plenty to get into and uh
but yes please be respectful of the
property and and and their business
their home and go through the website
right book yourself an appointment if
you're going to do that chrisa have been
so good to you and so I'm so happy that
you would emphasize that like these
people don't have to do this they could
just keep this hidden um and they're
good people I can't wait to meet them
personally and they've worked with you
very closely and so that's like just
something very important to emphasize to
people because we know how the Weekend
Warriors are people just show up um but
but but that being said show us some
more fotos so what we have here is the
ground radar happening will you show
will you go through a scan of shown us
some more photos so more people can see
these anomalies and aspects of this wall
so they can think for themselves
absolutely uh this gentleman's name is
Carl he's a geophysicist he's been
working with Chris up there and
collecting data and um was you know very
surprised from my understanding with his
findings um that's him that that's the
ground penetrating radar right there
um and um he did a lot of measurements
leveling um and different stuff like
that um measuring the length of the wall
the height of the wall the all sorts of
different findings we have all that
we're compiling it um there's plans I'll
be releasing data and making a video um
there's lots of other big plans in the
work for next year that I think people
will be really excited to to see uh
happen but it is an ongoing process I
know a lot of people just want all the
information right now and I know that's
how I like to get stuff I prefer when
Netflix releases the whole season
instead of one episode a week as well
but you know you got got to tune in for
some of it because we also have to kind
of parcel some of this out we don't want
to put things out prematurely as well I
gotta and you're also and I I know
there's certain things you can't share
on screen here but you are working and
doing some other things uh some big
projects involving this stuff and um
real quick to anyone listening follow
Mike on his channel wandering wolf
Productions it's on YouTube he's just
getting started on Rumble so the link is
in the description or type in wandering
Rolf Productions it'll come right up um
but follow him on YouTube
and follow him on Rumble help this guy
you're doing amazing things and like
you're this Gem of a channel that a lot
of other people haven't heard of yet so
I hope people will give you the love and
and go and hit that subscribe button
right now again just to talk you up you
blew Joe Rogan's mind and he hit the
Subscribe button which is kind of like a
really really cool thing uh when someone
as you know I adore Joe Rogan and he's
such an inquisitive person and he has so
many different interests and when
something gets his attention it's
usually something special and aot one
reason why he has the largest platform
because it's like a lot of people get it
you know they see it's like I find that
interesting too and so you wowed him you
wowed uh Graham Hancock as well so I
hope uh people will follow your work to
see because do we we were talking about
hey we're gonna talk about bck we're
gonna talk about a bunch of things on
this podcast and we've been focusing on
this wall um it's an easy one to it's an
easy Rabbit Hole to dive into for sure
uh but you know uh yeah the property it
does back up to that government land
just to touch on that other uh the other
topic too because it it is kind of
exciting some of the stuff that's
circulating around this not just the
interest of uh of of people um you know
major personalities like Joe Rogan or
Graham but um you know who've seen this
stuff and been interested or lik it and
supported it but also um you know that
that governmental interest that that we
briefly touched on was you know the that
you know years ago when this started
kind of coming to light well the
government started deciding they needed
to do geological surveys and or for
deposits of different types of minerals
and stuff out in the area and so next
thing you know they have black
helicopters flying all over their
property and over there some of that um
Chris the property owner has video of
that he'll be getting to me that I'll
probably be releasing if we have any
good footage you know it's been a few
years since um he took some of those
those those pictures but we hope to
release some of that too but the the
agency that they hired is a company
based out of England who's known for
doing surveys for countries around the
world one of the last things um that
they did you know they have a reputation
for damaging sites oddly enough other
ancient sites around the world so they
were hired to do surveys down in uh
Australia a just randomly happened to be
after a site was discovered down in
Australia and they blew that side up and
uh chocked it up to um an accident but
there was a site discovered next thing
you know there's they start saying a few
years later they start it starts gaining
interest they decide they need to do
geological surveys in that area they do
they blow up the site um why are they
doing so much research around sites that
all you know these geological sites of
deposits that always happen to be around
something of Interest right that's a bit
you know it's just kind of another makes
your eyebrow go up like yeah yeah you
know when I hear about black helicopters
flying over something after it gets a
bunch of attention I now know I need to
look in that direction like what's going
on here right will you will you please
keep showing us some more photos so
people could see of this wall because
some of the best photos that I've seen
um oh so look at that look how straight
that sucker
is yeah and and you know like I said
some of some sometimes the pictur is
kind of distort and make things occur
that one but but keep going because I
know you
what's Adam sorry oh that that that it
is straight I mean it is a straight line
and that's a much better perspective
there at the straightness but and when
we show you one of the shots from the
aerial drones again you could see that
it's literally just I love that shot
right there that's a good one and now
you know if I run my mouse over it here
there's there's things that seem like
they would be man-made like some of
these blocks here but then you see stuff
like here that maybe cracks over time
from weathering and erosion
right possibly even seismic movement but
the level of weathering on this
wall you know you know we depending on
how back how far back we may eventually
be able to date this could be
significant tens of thousands of years
yeah yeah I mean you can tell that
there's areas like this one here that
were all one solid piece at one point
that have broken off so you have layers
and stuff like this like this looks very
natural and and broken some kind of
break but you can can tell that all that
all used to be one piece as well which
is very nice
rectangle so we keep going in here and
that's Carl on the right he's the
geophysicist working at the site and
Chris the property
owner great
guy so there's some more work it's very
interesting to see some of it happening
real time like the the ground
penetrating radar and stuff I wasn't
aware that that's what it looked like
that you could just roller it down you
know um that's pretty cool um and it
starts making me think like man how much
do these things cost
because that is very easy to do if you
know what you're doing rent them I know
they're available for rent we should go
you know what I mean like yeah got some
ideas Rod take
one things start looking possible when
you can make things portable like that
and anyone listening like I encourage
people it's like look I'm a guy just got
off the couch and started pursuing a a
passion you did the same thing and it's
like hey guys like the world needs more
of this you can rent stuff you can get a
camera you can put on the internet and
then it can just go viral like you're
you're you had that video that came out
on the sage wall that got a bunch of
views and it just took you to a whole
other level B pretty much overnight
literally like it's like all of a sudden
a bunch of people are seeing it like and
and and here you are so it's like people
you
know you can make things happen in your
life all you got to do is just head in
the direction of interest and um but go
ahead I'm sorry I think you have stuff
to share here yeah no um it's just it
it's very exciting to see the work being
done and it is I I'm of the opinion that
the more the marrier um the more people
that get out here document stuff film
things film things in your area I I get
messages from people all the time
because I'm going to these places that
are kind of relatively unknown a lot of
times you know I'm getting me direct
messages from people in emails and all
sorts of stuff saying there's these
things in my backyard I I I do this
hiking tray all the time and I've always
seen this thing here go out and film
them you guys this is like everybody can
contribute there is nothing preventing
you from going out filming it and if
something is uh is decided that it's
just natural and it's not a thing so
what you had a good experience you keep
doing it it's part of the fun that's the
part I want to emphasize here because I
guarantee there's people in the comments
saying this is 100% a natural feature
I'm like first of all you don't know
that yet but that's just say that you
are correct what we're encouraging here
what's so great about this um and I look
at the same way like the rot structure
it's like Hey listen regardless of what
these things are you're bringing
something new to people that they've
never seen or heard of before and then
you're asking questions and they're gon
learn something new like for me although
I might be partial to think that the rot
structure is the most likely site for
Atlantis for so many reasons but even if
it turned out to be false I'm like what
happened to the Sahara Desert so the
same thing goes along the lines with
this with sage wall which is like if
this is totally natural and humans never
did anything to whatsoever well it's
like this is an anomaly that doesn't
look like any other volcanic Dyke
anywhere on Earth and this is an
opportunity to learn this is an
opportunity people to go outside this
opportunity for people to put down their
stupid smartphones and like you know go
purs go look at something with their own
eyes um and learn something in the
process I think I think I couldn't agree
more by the way and I think what a lot
of people continually Miss who take the
argument of that that like to argue with
people who ask questions about stuff
like this especially in regards to sites
like this is it is that you know the
scientific process generally I mean how
many examples do you have to have of
people failing a thousand times before
they find the right thing so you know if
if failure is the measure of uh uh of
your definition of somebody's success or
doing the right thing you're off track
let's keep failing at some of this stuff
until we we find the things we're all in
pursuit of the most of us are in Pursuit
pursuit of the same thing which is
finding new information and uncovering
this um you know shady past of ours that
we've been given um and and and and told
and the only way to do that is to keep
doing the work and sometimes the work
means Crossing things off and sometimes
you have to cross a thousand things off
before you hit that one thing yeah will
you as you're talking will you go over
to a couple more photos real quick you
have them lined up there I some of the
best photos some of these people haven't
seen yet keep go over another just keep
toggling a little just keep
going
oh the wall is
magnetic oh that's
cool if I didn't mention that before by
the way the wall is magnetic I just
learned something new you had mentioned
something to me but I hadn't seen it yet
how cool is that that's fun that's fun
and the reaction there's a you've seen
the
geophysicist working that's a good shot
right there brother but the there's the
there's a geologist also who's been
working on the
site um and we've got we've done lab
results on the stone and we've been
getting that back the level of magnetism
on the site um from what I understand
was
surprising to to to to um to them to the
geologist it was a higher than normal
level for um uh of iron and stuff like
that in these in these Stones you have
to understand too this whole area is
very and minerals and crystals and all
sorts of stuff
quartz and uh um so for this to uniquely
be at a much higher level than than the
surrounding area is some is saying
something um but watching them stick
that magnet on there and it just stick
to the wall it's pretty
amazing I love it let me see keep going
brother show us I'm I'm at the end there
on those pictures okay no worries um I
like how it like when you pan out on
this video and it shows you the
wall
right I mean
dude let's see that's just so
cool let's
see yeah right here that's my favorite
part look at that what you
know it doesn't look totally natural to
me I'm just saying I'm not saying that
these blocks these Stones weren't
something that existed there but the big
question is did ancient humans lift and
stack them together um I want to see I
have
another I have some photos that you had
sent me that shows just how straight and
even is especially from the aerial view
let me do a share screen on my end for a
second
here one
second and I want you to let me know
I've heard from multiple people that the
Drone video was definitely
what brought it to
to you know got at the level of interest
that it ended up getting I see can you
see this now what I'm sharing yes yeah I
can so I'm just gonna do a little uh a
little dump here
yeah and you said this a yeah see this
is one of the ones I was thinking of how
flush it is and you said it's over 300
feet long correct uh that sounds about
right
yeah it's
massive and it's it's it's really hard
to it's really hard to share with you
just how impressive it is standing up
next to it I
mean I went to it the first time and I
was just blown away but even the second
time that I went I had the same level of
reaction where I was just really are you
kidding me I thought it would hold less
it would be less impressive the second
time around coming out a year later and
it wasn't it was just as impressive real
quick can you see my mouse I can yeah
like when I see stuff like this you know
when I see things like
this like I'm not like right here that's
obviously natural those are some
fissures um you know so like just to
clarify you know we're again emphasizing
here that is this a combination of a
natural feature that was constructed and
pieced together by people and so we're
not saying that there's no evidence here
that this isn't natural the argument is
that is it something that that that was
that humans started playing with because
when I see pictures like that or manmade
that has is so old that it's been worn
down over time and has natural
influences on it I I will say that
previous picture that you just had um
that and then if you go to the next
picture that you were just
at that structure on the previous
picture is to the left of the wall here
so what oh little little note is that
there is a parallel wall that is in a
greater um state of disarray where the
rocks have collapsed and fallen over so
that last picture was a wall of
collapsed Stone but you can easily piece
it back together in your head you can
see where everything's Fallen that was
in a wall shape par exactly parallel to
the to the main wall I see very
interesting and one of the things that's
unfortunate like being out there in the
woods it can make it difficult to get
one picture that shows everything that's
around because like you're surrounded by
foliage and so yeah I love these let's
see here and so Chris and Linda have
been hard at work over the years um
clearing this area out um because all of
this so when they first found the site
from my understanding it was completely
covered in debris trees and
brush so this is the result of years of
clearing this away and hats hats off to
Chris and Linda for doing the work and
getting out here to clear this and make
it accessible and then not only that but
opening up their home and their property
to allow people to come in here and see
it for themselves how much are they
charging for tickets uh oh gosh I I
think the last time I checked they were
around
$40 right that yeah that that sounds
right I remember to enter the property
and explore the wall and theyy Chris and
Linda go to
$49.99 or 65 I mean I hate to do that
you know like but um you can charge a
little bit more just a little bit
because let them I hope they cash in on
this because like I want to go out there
and buy a ticket and check it out and I
hope this brings them abundance I I
couldn't agree more um because again
they don't have to do this it's their
it's their private land and you do have
to understand that when you're coming
out there you know you know I've heard a
obvious um mostly all of the put
feedback has been overwhelmingly
positive but I have seen a few comments
that are like $40 $50 whatever it's like
you guys got to understand every time
somebody comes out there they have to
stop everything that they're doing with
their regular day life and check people
in and let people on their property and
worry about people like respecting the
area there's lots of people that have
come out there and they they want to sit
down and burn things like incense and do
you know do do you know all the fun
hippie stuff yeah stuff go have sex on
top of that wall
yeah guys some sometimes especially in
the summer the area is so dry you're
really endangering the site so they're
you know they're really you know
extending their arms to people and I I
think that that that that the pricing is
more than fair and I couldn't agree with
you more there isn't a more deserving um
uh couple of people that than than them
um for making all accessible and being
proactive about um getting the
information and trying to find some
answers out here it's great yeah now you
were saying now we're going to roll this
over to exclusively on Rumble here in
just a moment to anyone that's listening
the link is in the OR that's listening
on or watching on YouTube the link is in
the description hit it right now it'll
be a seamless transition you go right
over there uh because we're going to go
into the ground the results of the
ground penetrating radar because like I
had made a video on this uh 10 months
ago I can't remember what earlier in the
year um and and a lot of people
everyone's asking it's like well let's
get ground Raider out there let's some
test uh and and thanks to you making
these videos it it has now happened um
but what's amazing is that well now
they've done it and there's actually
something to share so we're going to
share that exclusively over on Rumble um
let me fly through a few more of these
photos here uh I like this one um well
that's a good shot and by the way these
are all your shots you you took every
one of these photos and videos yes I I
like to
use that's something when I started Ed
traveling and doing the work because I
wanted to F use all of my own footage so
when you see my videos and stuff like
that that's all my footage and my in my
videos is um and I wanted to try to get
a different perspective of some of these
places and I knew that you know one of
the big places was long UK caves which
was a site that caught Joe's attention
Joe Rogan's attention and yang Shang quy
and I knew that when I got over there um
I could do something special at the time
those were my biggest performing videos
till the sage wall and that's exactly
what happened there was there was
nothing but like we talked about before
kind of blurry and grainy images of Yang
Shan Corey um and then I was able to
drop that video with Drone footage and
everything and just what an incredible
site and uh you know that kind of leads
into the comparisons I've been making
between Yang Shan Balck and and Awan
with these massive megalithic um quaries
and and structures these that that are
usually the top three mentioned when it
comes to the largest megalithic blocks
in the world are those three sites uh
bck always seeming to take the the
Forefront in that which I 100% disagree
with 100% disagree with China because
it's exponentially larger it's Yang Shan
without a doubt um it's not even
comparable in my opin w I've stood on
every one of those those those blocks
and cories yang sh Cory
is two ball
Becks it's so wild so I'm sure people
that follow me know that I went to Balck
in September and it blew my mind and you
were there just a few months earlier or
how long ago was it was you did that in
style man the your your traveling
partner on that trip was
wild amazing experience GS George St
Pierre to anyone aren't familiar yeah I
just the way it worked out him and I
were already following each other he's
into the Ancients and I was able to tag
along with him to Balck in Egypt and boy
is that for some ballc was my bucket
list like that's the one site so let's
talk about this real quick before we
roll this over to rumble okay so you
believe wholeheartedly that China dwarfs
it however that's back burner China for
just a moment and focus on what bulbeck
represents which to me and you and I I
know your thoughts on this but I'm like
if there was one site that was
definitive evidence of A Lost
Civilization that was far more advanced
than what was taught in school yeah it's
bulbeck and the trilon stones that make
up the the foundation of the heliopolis
we're talking 900 ton stones that
removed a mile and then lifted and
stacked over 30 feet off the ground
completely flush I've shared pictures on
this but I'm like for a site that was
said to be created by the Romans yet Ro
the Romans who are renowned for having
documented everything and this is the
one site at least as far as the
foundation goes that they do not
annotate who did it or when right and
I'm like when you're there you can see
the two or even perhaps three different
uh construction methods that it was
obviously built on top of um what are
your what are your thoughts on
Balck I
think
Balck I've been everywhere and balbec
is probably the most aming amazing side
I've ever been to it has everything that
you could ever want to look at it has
Nubs Cuts
Scoops Machining tool marks that that
look like that you have the some of the
largest megalithic stones in the world
you have this um comparable level of of
building here between these massive
blocks and precision fitting here to
these that are less precise and smaller
where you know and to even less and less
you know it's like it's just an amazing
site and some of it is laid out in such
a way that you can see the grand scale
of what it used to be in such a way that
you can almost imagine yourself being
there I can't think of another place
that I've walked through that felt like
transported me to another place in times
so seamlessly as ballbe and and and and
then then you take into account the area
that you're in and it just lends this
feeling of kind of excitement and
adventure to what you're doing right
because you know we heard gunshots going
off all over and not far from here at a
different site we actually got shot at
up on the mountain sides tell everyone
real quick it's in Hezbollah controlled
region of Lebanon it's in Hezbollah
controlled region there you're you're
very close to the border of Syria um I
think you could drive to Damascus in an
hour or two and um it's uh um yeah so
you know you're going through
checkpoints and all sorts of stuff guys
with AKs and uniforms like full on
You're Gonna Hear gunfire we heard
gunfire all the time while we were there
um you know thankfully all the whole
time we were in ball backck it was off
in the distance um but at the same time
you're meeting people that are
incredibly kind that want to talk to you
that want to meet you everybody
everybody was following asking what were
you doing I say YouTube instantly
following me oh very cool they had
YouTube and following us and made
friends and it was great real quick I
want us I want you to show us some more
photos but I'm going to take this
opportunity for us to now roll over to
rumble so everyone that's on YouTube the
link is in the description just click it
you'll follow us seamlessly there so at
this time I'm going to end it on YouTube
I hope you guys will hit the button
because we're going to share some
awesome photos of bulbeck but we're also
going to share the results of this
ground radar they found something it's
significant so it's worthy of your time
so with that said I'm going to go ahead
and hit the button on YouTube the link
is in the descript